ready okay welcome everyone thank you
for coming out in a nice spring evening
I think we have a real treat for you
tonight my name is Allison Jones I'm the
community relations manager here at
Barnes & Noble mobile Charlottesville
tonight we welcome author Joseph Weiland
share with us his new book Jefferson's
vendetta the pursuit of Aaron Burr and
the judiciary
generations of Americans have revered
Thomas Jefferson is one of our greatest
leaders highly principled optimistic
untainted by vindictiveness and they
have considered Aaron Burr as his
antithesis in Jefferson's Vendetta
Joseph Whelan examines the contentious
relationship between Jefferson and his
most dangerous rival Aaron Burr and
discovers a vastly different truth
extensively researched and told in vivid
detail Jefferson's vendetta of
challenges the blackened legacy of Aaron
Burr and shows the beloved Jefferson
mired in the kind of manipulative
politics that tradition has depicted him
as rising above the Richmond
times-dispatch says of this book's take
on the whole sorry episode the title
says it best this is a very interesting
situation having mr. Whelan here in mr.
Jefferson's County with his book showing
such a different view of him and I yes I
think he's very brave to be here he's a
graduate of the University of Wyoming
and the University of Colorado Denver
he's an editor and reporter for The
Associated Press and the Casper Star
Tribune in Casper Wyoming he's also the
author of Jefferson's War Americans
first war of terror 1801 to 1809 he
currently live in North Carolina
please welcome Joseph Leland evening
glad to be here in Charlottesville
beautiful city first I guess I would
like to say that
I did not set out to write a book
another book
second book about Thomas Jefferson I
edited Carolyn Graff who published
Jefferson's War America's first war and
tear became interested in the treason
trial of Aaron Burr upon reading an
episode toward the end of Jefferson's
war in which followed the later careers
of some of the principals at the Barbary
war 1801 1805 William Eden was his name
and he led famous march across the
Libyan desert to Derna captured Derna
and that led to the the treaty that
ended the war with Tripoli and as it
turned out we meetin was a witness at
the trial of Aaron Burr for treason in
Richmond 1807 and I used some of the
material from that trial which burr who
acted as his own lawyer
much of the time confront confront and
William Eaton on the stand and they had
quite an exchange and my editor asked me
to write a book about the of the treason
trial because not much has been written
about at em in some time so I set out to
do that and I ended up writing another
book about Thomas Jefferson because I
found that his hand was his hand was in
everything that happened in 1807 to
Aaron Burr and to John Marshall the
judge and Heath so what I'd like to do
is to start off with a summary that I've
prepared which will bring up to speed on
what this was all about and then it can
answer questions and talk about other
things too so I'll begin in 1807
thousands of people converged on
Richmond Virginia to see America's first
trial of the century former vice
president Aaron Burr was charged of
treason he was accused of plotting to
seize States West
Allegheny Mountains and also planning to
lead an expedition to conquer Spanish
Texas and Mexico but the stakes were
even higher than burrs life the very
fate of the judiciary hung in the
balance as well directing the
prosecution from Washington was calms
Jefferson in the middle of his second
presidential term Jefferson was a great
anime of birth and the federal judiciary
even before burrs arrest Jefferson had
declared that burrs guilt was beyond
question however the president knew the
government's treason case against
burrows week there's no hard evidence
that Byrd done anything to seize the
western states but Jefferson believed
that no matter what the outcome he was
sure to triumph because if burr were
convicted he would win outright burr
went free he could blame the judge and
the judge was his cousin Chief Justice
John Marshall of the US Supreme Court if
Marshall let burr go free
Jefferson believed Congress might be
outraged enough to permit the removal of
troublesome federal judges like Marshall
since 1800 Jefferson had worked
relentlessly to undermine the judiciary
and destroy Aaron Burr the judiciary
Jefferson believed was a stronghold of
the rival Federalist Party in 1802 he
had repealed John Adams expansion the
Judiciary Act of the judiciary and this
was the Judiciary Act of 1801 just
passed just before Adams left office
this this particular act expanded the
judiciary greatly and created a whole
new tier of judges of US circuit judges
and expanded the Supreme Court and added
many justices of the peace but Jefferson
and his managers in the House and Senate
managed to repeal this this act and in
1804 Jefferson directed the impeachment
of the most active enforcer of the hated
Sedition Act
this was Supreme Court Associate Justice
Samuel chase the Chiefs was acquitted
and ironically at this trial Aaron Burr
was a presiding judge as as the vice
president and president of the Senate as
burrs trial began John Marshall was
acutely aware that he and the Judiciary
both were in grave danger and that he
must walk a tightrope to save it Aaron
Burr too was cognizant of the deadly
peril that he faced in 1800 he had been
Jefferson's running mate
both Republicans were surprised everyone
including himself by tying Jefferson for
the presidency House of Representatives
finally elected Jefferson but it took 36
ballots as runner-up burr became
Jefferson's vice president that close
call convinced Jefferson that Burke
could wrecked Jefferson's plan for
Virginia dynasty in the president's
house
in other words Jefferson followed by
James Madison and James Monroe which was
exactly how it played out so Jefferson
and Madison turned the Republican press
lose on burr hoping to destroy him
politically and it did then they pushed
through the twelfth amendment changing
loyd Presidents and vice presidents were
elected now previously and in the
election of 1800 the presidents were
selected by electors selected by the
state legislatures in their states each
elector had two votes of equal weight
and he would cast the first vote for his
first election in a second for his
second selection for president vice
president or whatever but they were
equal vote the twelfth amendment changed
that so that the electors cast one vote
for a ticket and the political parties
would select the ticket with a president
vice president this was proved in 1804
also in 1804 Madison Jefferson kept her
off the Republican ballot that year and
ran George Clinton who's the governor in
New York is the vice president to
Jefferson and he was considered a safe
vice president because he was 70 years
old so he would not challenge the
Virginia dynasty in April 1804 burr ran
for New York governor knew that he was
not going to be on the ticket
the Jefferson along with the New York
Republican Party and Federalist
Alexander Hamilton all ganged up on him
and he lost three months later burr
killed Hamilton in their duel in 1805
burr returned to private life now
appeared one of the great villains of
American history James Wilkinson
Wilkinson was the general of the army
and unknown to everyone but the Spanish
he was a paid spy for Spain spy number
13 and he had been for almost 20 years
Wilkinson and Byrd been friends for 30
years
since the American Revolution Wilkinson
proposed they launched an expedition
against Spanish Texas and Mexico
filibuster that could only take place if
the United States and Spain went to war
by 1806 war appeared likely Wilkinson
and US troops faced a hostile Spanish
army near the texas-louisiana border now
rumors and reports of the burr Wilkinson
conspiracy were everywhere were in 70
men however start for Louisiana anyway
to join wilkinson and begin their
expedition Wilkinson got cold feet
made peace with the Spanish and he
betrayed Byrd to Jefferson and a letter
claiming he had discovered a shocking
treasonous plot he disavowed any
involvement even though he had suggested
the plan in the first place when
Jefferson got the letter he issued a
nationwide alert and burr was arrested
so the stage was set for the first trial
of the century proceedings began in May
1807 government prosecutors face to the
best trial lawyers in America
namely Aaron Burr and a man named Luther
Martin of Baltimore he was he was a
amazing hit an amazing memory he could
every site page after page of statute
and the law and what he liked to do
during a trial when he was arguing case
was to he would have a stone mug next to
him filled with rum she would sip
through from throughout the day he could
speak for seven hours at a stretch
maybe he's a guy and they the Baltimore
lawyers had a nickname form which was a
lawyer brandy bottle about five thousand
people came to Richmond to see the trial
doubling the city's population as a
result the proceedings were moved to the
largest room in Virginia at that time
House of Delegates chamber in the state
capitol grand jury was convened first
jury foreman was Virginia Congressman
John Randolph who's a cousin of both
Marshall and Jefferson all three men
were descendants of William Randolph and
Mary ition known as the Adam and Eve of
Virginia also on the grand jury were
three four three future Virginia
governors and US senators and three US
congressman so it was a it was a real
sharp a bunch of grand jurors Jefferson
and attorney general Caesar Rodney had
summoned 140 prospective witnesses to
Richmond not all them were asked to
testify though Andrew Jackson for
example had been served but when he
arrived in Richmond he stood by his
friend Aaron Burr ended up hanging
people from the Capitol steps about the
iniquity of the Jefferson and ministry
government's star witness course was
general the army Wilkinson who had
betrayed burr Wilkinson is a pompous man
who loved God in uniforms and he
traveled in an entourage
he arrived in Richmond in June and the
grand jury began questioning Wilkinson
behind closed doors and questioning went
on for four days revolved around a
letter that burr had sent wilkinson and
that and which had been the trigger for
a Wilkinson alerting Jefferson to this
plot letter had been written in code the
key was a pocket dictionary that both
men possessed writing letters and code
was fairly common in those days because
postal officials noop through all the
mail all the time this particular code
that they had set up involving this
dictionary was a series of numbers and
the first number would be the page
number second would be the column number
and the third would be the number of the
word down that column so it was a fairly
laborious process to both write a letter
in this code and decipher it Wilkinson
had sent his translation of the burr
letter to Jefferson but it was an
unfaithful translation it omitted the
first sentence referring to an earlier
letter that Wilkinson had sent to Burr
and Wilkinson rewrote parts of the rest
of the letter to the changes were
designed to conceal Wilkinson's role and
look at the conspiracy in the grand jury
room however Wilkinson was asked to
furnish the jurors not only with the
translation but the original coded
letter and the key this was a smart
group of men and they quickly figured
out the system and they discovered a
Wilkins hadn't tampered with the
translation so then the questions flew
and Wilkinson was led to admit that
indeed he had been in contact with furro
earlier but he claimed he was only
trying to draw out burrs plot
John Randolph didn't believe and moved
to indict Wilkinson for conspiracy to
commit treason by 97 vote the indictment
was rejected and this was a actually a
pretty significant vote because of the
grand jury was loaded up with
Republicans 14 Republicans and just two
Federalists on this grand jury so that's
what that vote mat was a five
Republicans had sided with the two
Federalists felt that there was evidence
enough to indict wilkinson Wilkinson
emerged from the grand jury room on the
verge of tears and complaining bitterly
about his treatment the end of June 1807
grand jury indicted burr and six
co-defendants for treason and violating
Spain's neutrality his trial was
scheduled for August
now prosecutors didn't dare put their
star witness Wilkinson on the witness
stand because Burt and Luther Martin
would tear his testimony to shreds his
credibility was pretty well shot so the
government case against burr flimsy to
begin with began to appear unwinnable
and as burr had hoped and prosecutors
feared it finally hinged on John judge
John Marshall's interpretation of the
Constitution's treason clause this along
the great moments Marshalls career as
chief justice career in which he made
the judiciary the equal the executive
and legislative branches Marshall was
chief justice for 34 years 1801 until
his death in 1835 and he in fact no one
has served that long sense as chief
justice he still holds the record
Marshall ruled that for there to be
treason there must be an overt act war
against the United States witnessed by
two people which is the exact language
of article 3 section 3 of Constitution
so he interpreted it strictly down the
line
now in other countries a person might
hang for merely wishing the death of his
nation's leader than the United States
that person would have to act on the
wish in the presence of two witnesses
this was deliberately written into the
Constitution at the insistence of
Benjamin Franklin who did not want to
see the abuses that had been that had
transpired in England and other
countries England especially they said
that valleys were filled with bullet
graves because of the persecution of
people who reviewed his dissenters but
it really hadn't done anything to
overthrow the the royal government or
anything he didn't want that to happen
in the United States so that's why it
was written that way
Marshalls strict constitutional
interpretation was the last word on
treason law until World War two so who
was Aaron Burr he's one of the most
intriguing figures in American history
my research I found that he is still
usually depicted much as the Republican
press portrayed him in the early 1800s
during their smear campaign against him
in other words as a mountain of
depravity however he came from a very
distinguished family his father was the
second president of the college in New
Jersey
Princeton University quite famous his
grandfather was Jonathan Edwards who was
a famed evangelist from New England who
wrote sinners in the hands of an angry
god which is still on a lot of college
English anthologies today when Burroughs
- is father and mother died and of
smallpox and then his grandparents
Jonathan Edwards and his wife came down
from Massachusetts to the raised Burr
and his sister who is Sarah he's four
years old I believe and
they got sick Jonathan Edwards took over
Aaron Burr seniors position as president
of college in New Jersey but within a
year he was dead and so is his wife so
in one year whole Jenner two generations
of hers family been wiped out by either
smallpox or cholera soberness
sister were raised by an uncle Timothy
Edwards who's a reverend in western
Massachusetts he Burt was applied for
admission to college in New Jersey and
he's 11 years old he's a very precocious
boy and he would have been admitted
except he was he was small even for his
age he just looked tiny and so they said
you'd have he would have to wait a
couple years we studied very hard he was
admitted when he was 13 and he graduated
in three years at the age of 16 is a
uncle thought that he would become a
minister too but after a year study
became apparent he was not interested in
that he's more interested in going into
the law then the Revolutionary War broke
out in 1775 he went into the Continental
Army as an officer and he participated
in the campaign against Quebec he was at
the battle Monmouth courthouse he was
also a training officer at Valley Forge
during that terrible winter his his unit
was so well trained that Washington sent
him to train a unit that had
disciplinary problems he got out in 1779
and finished his legal education and got
married he was an early abolitionist
superb lawyer he was what you would call
expose a proto-feminist who raised his
daughter Theodosian as
people raised their sons back in those
days and he kept a portrait of Mary
Wollstonecraft until the end of his life
later years it became a surrogate parent
to several children but he was certainly
flawed
he had a politician's failing of telling
people what he what he thought they
wanted to hear he chose his friends
badly in this expedition that he planned
was a very poorly plan Andrew Jackson
noted that Burr was as far from being
fooled as anyone he knew except when it
came to the friends that he made and
trusted why hasn't his reputation
improved with time there are some good
reasons for that first winters write the
history in this case was Thomas
Jefferson and Madison Jefferson was
known to go back and change his journal
entries and letters need be
second burr never believed in responding
to slander he had this called a
Chesterfield in approach to social
intercourse he believed that you need to
be a gentleman
that you didn't respond things were
untrue said against you and the people
would find the truth and by the time he
discovered he was completely wrong on
that it was too late although he did try
to he did start a newspaper to compete
with fit papers at the Madison and
Jefferson were supporting to smear him
but the editor was a real gentleman - it
was named was Peter Erving whose
Washington Irving's brother another
reason that burrs reputation suffered is
that his most important papers were lost
at sea along with his daughter
Theodosian early 1813 so there hasn't
been much to refute things that were
said against him by other people down
through the years
and what of Thomas Jefferson's behavior
in 1807 conducted the greatest dragnet
for government witnesses that would be
seen till the days following 9-1-1
he declared burrs guild beyond question
for you is even arrested he planned to
bring down John Marshall if burr were
acquitted in fact after the treason
trial which Aaron Burr was acquitted of
all charges
Jefferson sent his four managers in
Congress legislation to allow Congress
and/or the executive to to fire judges
say if they had a two-thirds majority
fortunately that went nowhere the
Congress at that time it was preoccupied
with problems with Great Britain which
had attacked our shipping off jr. coast
and attacked a US frigate the Chesapeake
in fact during the middle of the Aaron
Burr trial off the Virginia capes 1807
was the nadir of Jefferson's presidency
he was having trouble with James Monroe
he was the minister to Great Britain at
that time and he had he had signed a
tree of Great Britain which included no
no provision at all for for England to
stop impressing us seaman was the major
issue between the countries he was upset
with him over that and Ventura wanted to
come back to the United States and run
for president in 1808 and Jefferson had
made it clear that Madison was going to
be the next president and Monroe had to
wait his turn this was all happening as
during the burr manhunt as was its a
controversy between two of Jeff
Jefferson's two son and laws who were
happening both the congressman from
Virginia and they were feuding publicly
over which of them
Jefferson favored over the other
so he was having a rough time of it at
that point after the attack on the
Chesapeake Jefferson and Madison decided
instead of going to war they impose the
embargo which stopped all trade with
Europe and it was a failure so it was a
bad year for Jefferson any questions
this point yes now that's interesting
the the act of the supposed act of
treason occurred allegedly on an island
in the Ohio River called Blennerhassett
Island and it was actually as part of
West Virginia today but then was part of
Virginia so they were just the
government felt it was justified and
basing its charge against him there
another reason probably was that
Jefferson wanted the trial close at hand
so that he could send instructions down
every other day to the US Attorney
George hey who is prosecuting the case
and he did and hey sent daily reports
from Richmond to Washington made
couriers going back and forth and I
suspect a third reason might have been
to because Jefferson and Madison knew
that John Marshall would have to preside
over this case the way things were set
up that the Supreme Court in those days
the judges each had a circuit that he
was responsible for and he would
actually ride the circuit on his horse
and Marshalls circuit was Virginia and
the Carolinas so he would go out and he
would sit on cases with the US District
Judge in Richmond Raleigh Charleston did
that all the time so Jefferson and
Madison knew he would he would be there
in Richmond and I think it might it
it was an opportunity that Jefferson saw
to bring down Marshall that point he
Jeff Jefferson had believed since the
late 1790s that the judiciary had too
much power it had too much potential to
get even more power and initially he
believed that impeachment was the way to
go
and he had orchestrate the impeachment
to federal judges Samuel chase and then
before him
a federal judge from New England who
actually was about half out of his mind
and should have resigned from the bench
and he not only was impeached he was
convicted and removed of his really a
sad case and Congress but after her
Chiefs was acquitted Jefferson decided
that impeachment was not a good tool and
that the way to go was to get Congress
to pass either legislation or a
constitutional amendment to allow the
removal of judges and Jefferson believed
this as a matter of principle with him
that the judiciary should not be the
equal of the executive and legislative
branches me and and back then when the
country was still young and there were
no precedents on how to proceed with
this I mean today we take it for granted
three branches of government equal but
he believed that the judiciary should
not should not be equal it kind of ran
off on that in other questions yes sir
I was it fair to say that your book
suggests a Jefferson's sponsorship of
the 12th amendment of the Constitution
diluted the original concept of American
democracy
no not at all I think basically it it
was probably a good thing because it
simplified the selection of the
president and vice president made it
made it possible for political parties
to it made it possible for political
parties came to control more of the
process and they had before previously
you had a situation in 1796 for example
John Adams the Federalists got the most
votes came president and the number two
person was a Republican Thomas Jefferson
so you had two people of opposite party
serving together and after
cross-purposes - yeah yeah well that's
pretty much goes was the post
modernization yes it was I'm not sure
that the motive was entirely pure though
he I think it was also aimed at keeping
burr off to ballot in 1804 by some
chance he was able to marshal it there's
the great fear that Burwood marshall
support from discontented Republicans
and Federalists who were out of power
and somehow pull them together into a
coalition and become elected so that was
probably the prime motive the time
turned out to be a good thing now
I read the Hamilton book the recent
Chanukah book and really was quite taken
aback by all I learned about church
women
even if only part of that was true
really to fix it into the area
manipulative right this just thought it
was just so kind of shocking fortunately
I'm not a native Virginian I can claim
to Andrew Jackson suppose I was Joseph
but still I just wonder if you could
kind of as a three man Hamilton
Jefferson and bird you could just give a
couple of lines and assessment of those
before you got sure yeah I would say
Hamilton Jefferson and Madison founded
the the modern political system they
founded partisan politics they were the
fathers of partisan politics and that
happened in the early 1790s
and of course Hamilton found himself on
the opposite side of the divide with
Jefferson and Madison and so the the
infighting early on through the election
1800 was was really brutal as I'm sure
you've read the election 1800 puts
anything we probably seen in our
lifetime in the shade as far as just
malice now as far as burr burr is not
really the time the 1800 election what
you would call a national figure at all
he was put on the ballot by Jefferson
Jefferson wanted him to run as his
running mate and the reason was because
Burke was able to deliver New York State
to the Republican Party and he did it by
setting up it probably what was the
first political machine in New York City
using what then was called the Society
of st. Tammany was a yeah they they
operated out of Tammany Hall it was not
the Tammany Hall they built the Tammany
Hall Iran but indeed this is exactly how
they operated and they set up a card
filing system they had every every voter
on a card how much money they could give
how much time how they were going to
vote and or just organize it superbly
elected the slate of candidates from New
York City and they went to the
legislature and that tipped the balance
for the Republicans suit so anyway he
was he was Jefferson Madison and Albert
Gallatin had asked her to do this early
and 18 to deliver New York State and he
did it in the election of April of 1804
said the same hour 1800 he set it up on
New York City the New York Assembly was
Republican they were going to deliver
the electoral votes but to ensure that
they stayed Republican they wanted a New
Yorker to run with Jefferson so they
asked George Clinton the governor and he
was well known outside of New York very
well-known and Clinton said agreed that
he that he would but he said he wanted
to resign whenever he felt like it so
they decided that that wasn't a good
proposition they looked at the other
note the other political power center in
New York which was the Livingston family
but decided that Livingston wasn't
robert Livingston what didn't have the
name recognition outside of New York
sober was the third selection and he
turned him down flat because he wasn't
interested in being vice-president at
all and they had to talk him into it so
that's how he became a national figure
was because the delivered New York state
and very reluctantly became the vice
presidential candidate
I'm had a very difficult time especially
that I may not like it without a happy
folks through period happy times
immediately the Republican press was
turned loose on him and they brought up
all sorts of things just a moral monster
and the the press had a lot more leeway
and used it in the in those days to
slander people as their cooperation and
attribution were pretty poor and they
would just say things and they did and
in fact in the late 1790s now madison
and jefferson did the same thing to
george washington and Alexander Hamilton
smeared them and they paid newspapers to
do it and Washington was completely
exasperated with Jefferson at that point
but I think the way to look at Thomas
Jefferson now his he was a he was a
ruthless political operative any he was
a winner he won all the time except in
1796 one 1800 and he got his dynasty for
good or bad his methods worked and he
got his Virginia dynasty for 24 years
there was one person in this whole fair
was I guess you would call a victim and
his name is Harmon Blennerhassett and he
owned the island which this whole
disastrous expedition was staged from
the island in the Ohio River it's just
off of Parkersburg West Virginia and
it's a part of the West Virginia State
Historical parks system really an
interesting place to go to the
Blennerhassett that was an emigrate from
Ireland it inherited some money but then
he had made the mistake of marrying his
niece and this was really frowned upon
in Catholic Ireland at that time so they
left and use a lawyer
but he had inherited this money and he
bought his land on Blennerhassett Island
and built a mansion there and brought in
cattle and again raising cattle and he
was a scholar he had a fabulous library
and he he was kind of a amateur chemist
and studied literature and languages and
he played musical instruments
well burr in 1805 was scouting out what
he was going to do after he was after he
was vice president he used roon in
politics he had lost the New York
governor's race exhaust the vice
presidential ticket off the ticket with
Jefferson he had shot Hamilton and was
wanted for murder in New Jersey so he
didn't feel like he could go back to New
York City and practice law again he
thought he'd be arrested and spirited
away to New Jersey and hanged for
killing Hamilton and a duel so he teamed
up with wilkinson and he went down he
bought a houseboat hitch
$433 and sailed down the Ohio River in
Scouting things out seeing where he
could watch this expedition from there
were supporters whatever so he landed at
Blennerhassett island and he was a very
charming man he made friends with harmon
Blennerhassett his wife and persuaded
them to join in so when this whole thing
collapsed in early 1807 and everybody
who's arrested Harmon was charged with
treason as well as burr he's one of the
other six co-defendants and as a result
of this even though he was he was never
convicted of anything
he lost the island he lost his mansion
he lost all of his property everything
and ended up going back to Great Britain
and I think died number of years later
just poverty-stricken on one of the
Channel Islands between the English
Channel so if there was a victim it was
him he was he really believed in burr
and he believed the promises that he
would be paid back and he never was
after this bird went to Europe for four
years he lived a long time after this he
lived until he was 80 years old 1836 he
was disgraced ruined creditors were
after him but so he got got on a ship
and he went to Europe 1808 he stayed for
four years and he nearly starved to
death - he tried to raise money various
meanings he tried to enlist support for
his schemes one was to for Great Britain
- to help him capture a Cuba to Cuba
over from Spain the nothing worked he
ended up living in a garret and Paris
unheated in the winter half frozen to
death
starving translating books from English
into French for money for food money and
one of the books he's translating he
realized that slandered him but he
needed the money so bad that he went
ahead and translated it so he came back
to the United States in 1812 and landed
in fact on the very day that neg States
declared war on Great Britain and his
daughter had Theodosius had married a
man in the South Carolina named Joseph
halston he was Kim Hughes the governor
at that point in 1812 and they had a son
his name was Aaron Burr Alston and Aaron
Burr thought the world to him they did
too well at soon after he returned the
United States the boy died he was just
11 and it was a real shattering event in
the family and the adults his health
just crumbled under this under the
strain of this and she that they feared
for her life her husband dead and so he
and burr arranged to have her get on a
ship and sail to New York to join her
father thinking the the bracing northern
air would would help and all these and
she was raised in New York too but less
than a week after the ship left South
Carolina that vanished at sea and was
never seen again and on that ship were
the her father's most important papers
which he had left with her when they
went to Europe and that she was bringing
to him and they just disappeared
thinking was that there was a British
blockade or off the coast that reported
a gale hitting Cape Hatteras about that
time then all these wild stories
circulated and books were written novels
magazine stories about what happened he
does in one there are two other versions
one was that some of the crew members of
the ship were in fact pirates and had
mutinied overwhelmed the the captain and
crew taken over the ship made everybody
walk the plank and then had taken the
ship and sailed away with it although
everything on him
the the other story which was kind of
intriguing was that the records of the
Outer Banks of North Carolina they were
called records they were basically land
pirates who would by using false alights
and signals would lure ships aground on
the Outer Banks and then they would roll
out and kill everybody and and strip the
ships while the goods this story was
given more credence when late I was
after mid-century the 19th century this
elderly woman was dying in a cottage in
Nags Head North Carolina doctor was sent
for he came out and he noticed in this
humble cottage a portrait of a woman a
young woman dark hair light skin dark
eyes a black dress and she said that her
husband had found that portrait and a
trunk of fine clothing on the ship that
supposedly had was found empty just
floating off the coast there and they
had rowed out there's no one on the ship
so they had taken the what was on the
ship and kept it for years conjecture
that that portrait was Theodosius off
fifty dosia Breuer Olson but and and the
doctor obtained that portrait and the
clothes of the trunk of clothing which
also was found in the woman's cabin
which included a black fail on a black
dress very nice material but the the
Alston family
never really was able to claim that that
portrait was Theodosius never proved one
or the other it's probably probably was
not there's a lot written about that
it's a green mystery the early 19th
century questions yes do you know
anything about and were introduced in
Dali painting Tod to James Madison in
1793 yes yes I do
yeah that was that was interesting that
did happen brewer was a u.s. senator
from New York State at that point and
had arrived in Philadelphia he was
staying at a boarding house it happened
to be run by Dolly Todd's mother and he
became good friends with her and about
that time Dolly arrived at the boarding
house Toshi was a new widow she had a
baby and BER became great friends with
her and in fact such close friends at in
her will she she that she wrote about
that time she said that if anything
happened to her she wanted her to take
care of her baby
so Brewer was looking out after and he
said he knew this bachelor friend of his
that he had gone to college with that
might like to come over for dinner and
it was James Madison and he so he
introduced them and they married soon
after that they were college classmates
at that time where exactly did he
introduce
build in what place oh it was that did
until about here number wait it was at
that boardinghouse they mad at James
Madison was invited over for dinner at
the boarding house and that's how he met
dolly and they took it from there
did she attempt to defend birth later
years is there any record of her trying
to befriend him in any way
well when Brewers in Europe his daughter
Thea does he was trying everything to
get to the problem was the embassies in
England US embassies in England and
Paris doing everything make sure the Bur
did not get back to the United States
they were giving him a hard time and so
Theodosius aware of this and she was
trying to pull every string that she
could and that was one of the things
that she did was to contact Dolly
Madison wrote her a letter and asked her
if there's anything she could do for her
father and Dolly wrote a letter back
saying do you really regretted it but
there really wasn't anything she could
do but then shortly after that her was
granted got his papers and he came over
here so there's speculation that perhaps
she did use your influence which is what
I understand she said Jefferson was
arrested positive in local objects with
are burned
what happened with sense monofins
artists and therefore character in
relationship to this association with
Jefferson and this data against hmm
Madison's role is always very shadowy
throughout but he was from what I can
understand from my readings Addison was
the one who got things done
Jefferson was kind of the political
theorist Madison was the practical man
they worked together as a team and it's
hard to pin down exactly who did what
when because they were very careful not
to leave records of things that they did
the way that you determined their role
was to look at the outcome and of
Colleen when Jefferson was president and
Madison Secretary of State Congress did
everything that they wanted them to do
they controlled Congress absolutely
Madison actually was probably the better
politician than Jefferson Jefferson more
of a theorist Madison the practical
Politico but I'd like to see more
written about James Madison he was an
excellent politician he was he wrote
much of the Constitution he had a huge
role in founding a this country he did
not have a good presidency he was
probably a better working as part of a
group or as in tandem with another
strong person kind of my take on him
another interesting thing I'll just
briefly mention is the Hamilton birth of
animosity and where did that begin from
what I can determine now it began in
1791 1792 and burr was appointed by the
New York State Assembly to the US Senate
he replaced Philip Schuyler Philip
Schuyler was Alexander Hamilton's
father-in-law and that's where their
rivalry began right there
Hamilton acquired the habit of writing
letters making remarks about Burr and it
went on for 12 years
they almost dueled once in 1799 and when
Hamilton was killed John Adams remarked
that basically that he had a coming is
about time this had been going on for
more than ten years he was not surprised
or did he mourn Hamilton
it's very interesting about the founding
of the country and the relationship
between Hamilton and Washington which I
did I can do nothing about - lemon and
then Hughes all the fighting between
Washington and Jefferson really
surprised me 10 like bitterness and
stuff going on all the time between
these commands who we have talked of is
Virginia and different founders it
really is it's really worthless and I
look forward to reading it and it's
certainly the he likes Hamilton and that
comes through in the book but just the
history that depict really it's just
fascinating
I think it's interesting that people are
four years of view these men as icons
you know kind of marble statue men
basically and now we're starting to see
more the human side of what they're
really like
and which I think makes them even more
remarkable because you see them as human
beings who completes these amazing
things that lasted till today they
weren't gods or anything they weren't
they were extraordinary men tonight what
goes on in today's politics nothing
when you look at all that went on and
1800 is easier to look at what goes on
today and have faith in the country is
going to go forward but sometimes it
just things like passion and the
bitterness